yeah oh and the [ __ ] ring and welcome to
punch-drunk sports guys we're proud of
our new sponsor [ __ ] command
commander erection enhancers that's
right here tell us a little about it oh
it's fun to watch you I think it's a
[ __ ] ring I think it looks like a bottle
opener it looks like you got your dick
stuck in a bottle opener rich who hasn't
done that yeah go to commander erection
enhancer calm tell post rock music oh
Tripoli and just have your dick fall off
use the code trick guys what a great
time to be alive in sports we're
entering the what I call the golden
months of sports September October and
then the other great one is in fact I
think April
April's the other go in March or April
you know so ah very excited how are you
Jason I'm extremely excited for Thursday
ah alkanes Eagles
oh [ __ ] scam Eagles get their banner
hung and then they get hung Oh snaps you
call the big win I think so why can't I
hear myself I think so an hello there I
am bowls is starting I mean he did you
know get him a Super Bowl win but I'd
rather face Falls than [ __ ] homeboy
yeah we are live live we are live from
New York City
okay we're lives wise region mistakes
Lewis is uh we're patching in with
Legion of skanks and re Zoe okay this is
great audience because he was doing a
legion of skanks podcasters yeah I guess
I'll make time for my pottery they've
gone for five weeks yeah so I thought he
was Jason where you gonna be uh I will
be at the all things comedy down till
they figure it out it's gone I'll be at
the all things comedy festival with all
of us here and all of your good friends
at all things comedy at the end of
October so come to that and that's about
it for now what about you guys tomorrow
night
that is the fifth September fifth we
have a sold-out tin foil hat comedy
night at the Comedy Store but if you
want to come the every show that is put
on there is something there's a group of
people buy tickets and don't show up
we've got guest list last time show up
if they said sellout show up we want to
have a packed room we have a bunch of
Industry coming ah where else September
14th and 15th or 15th and 16th scuse me
September 15 16 I am at what 14 15 14
15th I am at the comedy corner or a
corner comedy club in Niagara Falls go
to corner comedy comm grab your tickets
now tickets are selling I have a lot of
family going there and then October 3rd
I am at Brea with Sam Triple E and his
weirdo friends I have like you're with
yourself that's Sandra Lee and his weird
old friends okay so it's gonna be Mike
Catherwood Mike Tully the smash brothers
George pres a myself those tickets are
now on sale at the Brea dot improv calm
grab your tickets and comedy chaos has
just been announced for next week Joe
Rogan Kyle Kinane and a whole Russell
Peter so that's it that's it that's the
stuff um have we figured it out there
they are take their time okay we have
two guys in different levels of clothing
one guy is built for winter and the
other one is that some nudist colony one
looks like does not eat yeah sorry well
re eats well he did a lot of coke so I'm
gonna say no he didn't eat a lot when
you mean the drugs he found on the
ground okay so here's what's going on
Bob we got a nice-looking studio that's
their new studio it looks nice it looks
nice is he also scoping in so Dave Scott
are we all skyping in from different
than what's happened I think it's their
progress in our pocket
look into the camera they start talking
to us we'll turn it on no this just okay
I like what is it - welcome to the water
no you know how hard it is to say this
is the worst episode ever and I say it
it is leaps and bounds wars episode ever
and we've done so many episodes and I'm
like this is the king I don't know if
we've had a good one I don't like what
Aaron gets worked up either when Aaron
gets mad I feel like this is really
stupid why we're doing this
well we're doing it because Ari is a
selfish [ __ ] okay he'd rather do
another show but this thing's like
unbelievable to me it's like dude you
have a podcast you get paid off it I'm
rich I don't care I'm a Jew all right go
give all my money to the current she
needs it what you also give me five
minutes to prepare for I think that's
right when we found out about it - I
texted on the way Aaron Olynyk is there
showed today there's a lot of
communication there's a why wouldn't
there be a show I don't know what I
don't hear from anyone I get paranoid
that I'm like driving in traffic what do
the funny thing is is last week almost
was it yeah two weeks ago I was gone and
then at Monday I get a text from Aaron
at like two twelve twelve o'clock in the
afternoon it's like so I guess there's
no punch-drunk today and I go yeah cuz
it's Monday and he goes I told Sam and
Johnny that we had to do Monday instead
of Tuesday I'm like this is the first
I'm hearing of it Johnny stop eating
those [ __ ] bars look at Ari
it's like what you don't need your shirt
off there's no poison that haim there
now this is uh big Jay is that a is that
a skunk streak doesn't you always have
that though no sometimes a lot yeah yeah
but I don't think like you said all the
way back the skunk's great I think
sometimes it's just the front there's it
just male pattern baldness hunting
ghosts Oh hearing hunting God doesn't
want on cameras who you like well the
webcam
is not attached to hey you guys feel
free to drop that whole thing so we
could do a [ __ ] show okay all right
we'll kill okay so let's talk about
football coach let's talk yeah let's get
something going what we talked a little
bit on the patreon which you did make it
thank God thank God yeah I would have
fallen asleep what about the Mack trade
about the Mack trade right now Colin
coward he's just going [ __ ] nuts
worst trade ever on the history of time
I don't know about that I mean that
[ __ ] Herschel Walker trade pretty
much built the Cowboys you know right
gave them an era I don't think that's
gonna happen for the Bears from this but
I do think I found it I was shocked I
didn't think he was gonna get traded
right I thought you guys were gonna pony
up and it's to me it's like all fake
money anyway oh it is like oh you could
say that number what do you got 144
words is like the most any defensive
player ever got you could have said 300
million and I'm just like whatever the
number just keeps going up up up up
every year right I never see all of it
anyway right so it's like fake numbers
anyway right so Tony up and give them
the guy fake numbers ah but there is a
cap yeah and when your team sucks on
defense you're gonna give a giant chunk
of to guy that defense is never going to
get better so you're going to think some
argument is some point well yeah and the
other thing is you got a lot for them
got two first rounders I'll take it
I mean not like in the next two years
but like one next year and then one two
years later we get another version of
Cleo Mac right if you guys have a bad
[ __ ] really bad season or you're like
let's say you're in the top ten and you
can move up to one that kid from Ohio
State Joey BOCES brother he's better
than Joey Bosa oh right two sacks on a
touchdown in the first [ __ ] game and
he's a defensive end yeah we'll get him
hi guys are you there still nothing okay
this is like I just feel like we're
ghost hunting at this point well that's
it that's an image first team in the NFL
you hear the Jets are gonna suck
bills the bills probably won't be great
I think Arizona's gonna [ __ ] to bed a
lot of people don't really yeah I think
Arizona's why I mean Sam Bradford gets a
concussion brushing his teeth
that guy's always hurt behind him is
Josh Rosen who you know couldn't I
couldn't beat out
Bradford hey rather than Larry
Fitzgerald they don't have a receiver
real quick I wanna I gotta check in with
ever and welcome to the Tim Foyle and
welcome to punch-drunk Sports Legion
asking swab cast go on we should just
throw a tinfoil hat in there too yeah um
what we'll be saying Oh who's bad yeah
um Raiders I think you guys aren't gonna
be good I mean I don't think you make
the playoffs I mean I think Raiders I be
the Raiders of that and you can blame
Gruden on this they're the oldest team
in the last 18 years of average age
almost 29 is your average age player and
that's the oldest average age since 2000
so in 18 seasons it's the oldest team in
NFL and then they just jettisoned their
youngest you know this guy's a four-year
player that was Defensive Player of the
Year two years ago yeah he's good this
episode is we're gonna get murdered on
we're gonna get murdered on this episode
oh yeah
where are you [ __ ] on by the list it
sounds like we're listening to
air-traffic controllers hey can we just
stop the podcast at this point because
there's no real point putting this out
um let's continue the podcast let's just
hang up on everybody else okay that's
fine I'm sorry it's just not good the
audio I mean if that's their audio it
sounds like we're talking so Bob sounds
like we're [ __ ] running from
terminators they're like if you hear
this you're not alone the resistance is
strong it would work like are they gonna
do their show and we're gonna do ours
but we'll talk over each other like I
don't really under we're all just are we
all talking to each other well it's also
one of those ideas it's like hey I'm
behind the idea I love all those guys I
miss having already on this show for the
last two months I'm glad he has a new
podcast
but you know it's like if we're gonna do
something like that tell us instead of
he told us at 11:05 this show starts at
11:00 okay like on the way here he's
like what what time we start and I'm
like probably right I was already here
like 10 I say so 10:45 we should just
Auto cut out all the rest of that and
just start it right now it's like me
just talking and just I start to show
because that our earlier stuff was so
bad you know just like he's giving great
analysis I don't think it's as loud as
you think yeah I don't think they wear
Aaron's always good at that stuff like
when Max is in here crying like I didn't
hear it at all like I thought that's all
you what a good mom what my baby's over
there she's out of cigarettes
remember when she also had a huge
blowout in the studio and I did change
her in front of that important guy
what's the important there's so many on
the movie got it was on the movie guy's
podcast Leonard Maltin the famous movie
critic from Entertainment yeah and I
changed her on that couch didn't be a
known as famous for critiquing movies
like got the sweet gig yeah it's it's a
useless kid it's like to me the weather
guy I mean we're famous for talking
about [ __ ] and cocaine so I you know
take that any day over movie critic I'm
sure he has a lot more money than we do
well after I take Artie's cash and split
it up nurse I think we're good to go
you wouldn't even know yeah have you
watched uh those are yet seasons I
watched two two seasons - uh-oh so good
it gets way better let me just say
something when they kill off Jason
Bateman's character at the end I forgot
about a game it's [ __ ] it gets really
good bro really good it gets a lot
better they don't kill his character um
so or do they offense my favorite thing
is that if you want
Oh's arcs and then you go watch better
call saul they have to be better call
saul has to be like oh my God we're so
slow compared to this well I thought the
first three were slow in Ozark oh it
gets crazier oh yeah dude by Episode
four I couldn't stop the first three I
was kind of like I don't remember some
of the [ __ ] they're television like do I
need to go back and re-watch like the
last two episodes and then by Episode
four I was just through booking bro I in
a day and a half I know in 36 hours I
watched all 10 hours of that Ozarks is
Bert Kreischer special okay
better call Saul is Nina right it's like
slow
nobody's enjoying this what do we do I
is it it's a great show it's just so
slow compared to Ozarks now right and I
don't know what I was arc so I feel so
what is it's two seasons on Netflix
second season just came out Friday
Jason Bateman kind of did you watch
blood line no blood lines you would like
to boy shows no it's like drama like
kind of like you watch the blade that
Breaking Bad is kind of Breaking Bad us
like breaking bad but it's a boy show
yeah what's a girl show by the way
Bachelorette Keeping Up with the
Kardashians like just everything that's
pure garbage not real orange is the new
black right now we're watching we're at
the groove me and Jeff we're watching
this maids tale or whatever that shit's
cold handmaids tell me watch that no you
have to watch what you want no usually
no he won't watch the shows I just named
he like picks of the ones like the
center and Castle Heights have you seen
Castle Heights is on Hulu it's good it's
Stephen King made it oh I've heard about
Castle Rock Castle Heights is a street
by me I apologize then it's also an
elementary school what's going on hello
hello are you guys there yeah yeah I'm I
I'm just blew us on the phone we're
trying to try to make this work okay
this is a good pocket right now we're
live
all right how are you guys good
how are you Luis Congrats on your big
win buddy I watched the fight a Congrats
you did great you look good student a
waste out of you the new studio yeah
everything is great over here and I am
really I really want to get on there to
gloat and rub it in your stupid la faces
but we need to figure it out Bobby won't
you think have your poster
Bobby's our producer Oh God have your
producer get on the line with Bobby
right now because we think we know what
the issue is we think we can get
everybody off cameras and everybody can
we go back and forth right now got to
get him on the phone right now with
Bobby and he's gonna give him a couple
sorry Wow here give it a give you
producer - Bobby here's Bobby but is
your Bobby Bobby producer oh my god this
is not gonna work we can't we can't
transfer you know Bobby you think Bobby
Bobby could you hang out please you're
live on our show couldn't be more awful
he thinks he just like randomly called
us up I'm talking on a black handheld
phone like yeah let me walk out of the
room with the caterer dude well he hell
with the caterer
he did say [ __ ] these guys and now he's
just gonna call him now sir I'm sorry
yeah yeah I mean I'm all behind the idea
but like let's have some rap so here
knows little at 11:05 the first I win
that we gotta listen I got here 10:45
I already hits me up what time are you
starting and I go 11 probably 11:05 nany
and Sam are probably be like a minute be
ready at 11:05 basic were you late - and
then you should own me
yeah though you were super late so far
nine minutes late which is average for
me
you because if your soup last week you
were 30 minutes late
and here's and then you were like why'd
you start mining you start without me
hey nanny came to the comedy chaos last
week and just couldn't find parking so
she drove off sad no I look for parking
for 20 minutes and like that's when I
get my anxiety and like panic attacks is
when I can't find parking doctor I said
to Dana yeah and I had to go oh she was
looking for parking for 30 minutes she's
in a [ __ ] full-blown I was in my
driveway like crying I can absolutely
it's like my fun night out so it's like
I get to go out I really look forward to
those nights and I was we're gonna edit
all this out
I actually like it this is classic
classic people are gonna say this is the
worst episode ever listened to I mean I
think it's just gotta go down like that
I would pay somebody to edit I mean I'll
pay giant edit out all the crap but
talking about this makes it worse
because it's gonna end up being a
40-minute show so let's go
Oh where's Johnny I want to [ __ ] it
let's do matchups let's do some matchup
of what do you mean of our football
coming up what else is new anything new
going on your life you mean a weak one
yeah
I'm just ready for football man red zone
starting up Sunday it's great that the
Falcons are playing Thursday night so
I'm gonna just enjoy that game and not
be at work right and then and then it's
[ __ ] go time we got to fantasy dress
today the punch-drunk draft is is
tonight hi did you you watch the video
of the guy tone his kidded that Santa
doesn't exist that was pretty funny man
welcome what we label this our worst
episode and then somehow figure out a
way to put out another episode this week
cuz it's bad I mean we can keep talking
about how bad it is that'll make it
worse because every two seconds
something else comes up we're sorry
what's come on now it's like we can't
even get a group going and I got em poor
Aaron's yelling at Johnny cuz
really was a yummy he was yelling you
know hair produced me I feel bad the
other day I think I saw Aaron's wife I
think she had a shiner she had a lot of
makeup she did yeah oh yeah big shiner
probably doesn't listen I don't know I
don't know no she kept calling me about
it she's like this guy's a maniac what
am I gonna do he's very mad I go well
what did you do this time she goes I
didn't put enough mustard on his
sandwich and I'm like well [ __ ] you
gotta get it together
you know me my mustard sandwiches ha ha
ha ha so I'm gonna start calling him Oh
mustard sandwich good old mustard over
there stuffed crust pizza
can you believe crazy Asians is still
[ __ ] going now is every Asian in
history time go and see this movie I
know
probably that's like you know I love how
they put it out like it's a cultural
thing but it's like it's obviously a
business it's like the liberal wink that
you've seen that movie have you ever
your liberal friends anybody I hope
they're all more people more Asians go
see that movie less driving am i right
guys what is it about thoughts it's
about a girl who's dating a guy and
finds out that he's it's just one Asian
who date's another Asian and then
they're just like how everybody's super
crazy just imagine all your least
favorite Asian comics do an Asian comedy
together in the movie so it's like a
yellow rom-com oh now it's like the
number-one grossing rom-com in the last
10 years well I guess good for them I
auditioned for it they're like what are
you even doing here
so did Bobby Lee and they're like no
you're not Chinese you can't do it like
that's video yeah I did he's devastated
yeah the only Asian that didn't get in
it
well dr. Kensi and he's Korean and he's
like [ __ ] it put him in there I mean
yeah eventually you gotta [ __ ] I mean
the burns trying so hard to go there
he's just taking pictures of him seeing
the movie 30 times he's like let's make
up for the white part of me Daniel is
here to know
he just I watch his Instagram he's like
going back for more you're like oh god
dude oh man you know what's funny about
that he's great he's doing a lot of aw
he shouldn't love his own stuff man he
shot a movie on amazing Jonathan and now
he should here we go here we go by the
way can we all agree this kids a little
too old to believe in Santa that Chad
looks like the child I thought that was
the child on the right so he's in our
league yeah this guy's in our league
Santa doesn't exist like disbelief
[Laughter]
that's me when I couldn't find parking
that's great I knew that was gonna be
funny guys in that guys in he better
make the draft you imagine destroying
your child's life and then missing the
draft Oh
Ari's Ari the producer of the worst
punch trunk episode ever
that worked my god this was shows bad
idea how to run a studio trust me trust
me
that thing's like literally two minutes
and you go oh two minutes are gone by
and he's like oh another two minutes and
like so they're not literally two
minutes do the [ __ ] worst well all
that uh the funny thing is is that you
know it's so chaotic there's 50 people
talking in there we're trying to every
time we get into a segment then you guys
would all pop up and then Gomes goes
yeah just want to get this together so I
can call in and [ __ ] on all you [ __ ]
[ __ ] from Los Angeles I'm like that's
that's the end game of all this the end
game is I'm gonna get [ __ ] on by you bye
Felicia
yeah Louis's uh Louis's got this new
Michael Bisping way of promoting now
where's like he challenges people and he
talks [ __ ] on Twitter
and then everybody's like oh hey you
little two-faced but you know it's like
trying to promote a fight or some [ __ ]
like that and I just got a laugh it's
it's real fun good good job Louis it's a
lot of fun all right welcome back how
was I your nine month vacation oh it was
seven weeks I was getting slept in my
own bed it was fun as [ __ ] though oh god
it was fun are you gonna shoot your Jew
hour yeah I still got more work to do
but it's all tight now for them on the
road it's all tight but I still got more
[ __ ] to put in what do you know what do
you what do you gotta do what do you got
tighten I got a arab-israeli stuff I
don't have anything on that
Oh Marv Jew propaganda yeah [ __ ] like
that okay successfully accomplished 9/11
the way you're holding your phone the
way you're holding your phone I
literally feel shaded by your nose I
feel like I feel like if it was raining
I wouldn't even get wet are you glad to
be back Belle oh yeah I'm glad to be
back it was such a good time dude you
should have seen me go to [ __ ] it I took
the old Sam Tripoli idea okay did she be
good and I just took I just took a
smoked ham list what do you mean the way
you used to have a smoked ham list okay
so who he's smoking this all over man
all those [ __ ] Oxford Cambridge [ __ ]
like theater based and I was like I'll
show you they're like oh but at least we
do a a theme it's so much better than
you guys it's like I'll show you a theme
you [ __ ] faces hope so you know we
just started wrecking shop yeah yeah I'm
like America [ __ ] we did his
way better than you so you're not even
close you should have made the call and
bomb them so what did now now when you
are when you did your show and you were
with all these other guys from other
countries and you went up and you
devastated was it almost like when um
back to the future when Martin McFly
starts playing the guitar crazy and
everyone's like what is this rock and
roll yeah that's what comedy is we're
done trying with this by the way they
kept texting me I go like wow yeah
as your leader don't answer I already
not so high is your girlfriend glad to
be back is they just dick for days now
you're just pounding out just to make up
for all the lost poundings
yeah I'd gone to period into her oh oh
dude you you hit it so hard she bled
that's that's a sign of good lovin how
many STDs come back with ya and ya know
dude you're a loyal guy right Ari I'm
loyal to [ __ ] my beliefs Ari I heard
you took a [ __ ] in the Adriatic is that
true hold on one second Oh beat it
that's it I gotta go want that up oh
these guys have no idea how to run a
[ __ ] show here yeah the studio looks
nice I mean like you know we're doing a
show ready for what he goes what do you
want me to be ready for a mic it sounded
on our end it sounded like listening to
like air traffic controller when the
volume was low you're like hey dude I
got this cool new app it's a police
scanner and you can listen to [ __ ]
crimes in your neighborhood about a
police scanner in five different cities
at once yeah like we are going into a
system I'm like what do you mean what's
there so you want them to redo their
system right now you [ __ ] idiot what
are you talking about it's you you're
not ready hey Ari what was the female
comedy like Candice was asking earlier
what was what was the female comedy like
over there and I didn't burn was it like
I really care was the muff comedy strong
oh okay well here it is generally
they're way more equal their women are
way more equal there oh so they're just
all kind of shitty oh so they're equally
shitty yeah well it might be like fourth
grade level where's the seventh grade
level but it's just I can't tell the
difference between that so it's like you
know all immature like undeveloped stuff
all right I heard you took a show this
is a little bit here there there's a
little bit here there that's good all
right you take a [ __ ] in the sea is that
true I took a [ __ ] in the Adriatic Sea
that's just rude to your [ __ ]
forefathers
you can't just say that and not beat
that out okay okay Croatia after
Edinburgh which I hear is beautiful oh
my god it was great and the chicks are
so [ __ ] hot how hot dude like what
would the nanny be in Croatia what would
what would she be no she would be a
[ __ ] Barb's come on be nice a nanny
yeah super how you just turn a corner
like what are you doing I hear what
you're saying but are you jerking off
faster scratching my side
okay that's forward let's rewind a
little bit from the hot chicks you seem
to make a jump from [ __ ] in the sea
to a lot of pretty girls yeah we got
sidetracked okay so so I went to this
place it was like deserted [ __ ]
houses was reading my book then I saw
this part of the beach that's like just
rocks and so I went up around there
you just find little crevices we can get
naked you just get naked and swim in the
Adriatic it's [ __ ] cool like no one's
around you and once you're out under the
water they can't see that your dick and
balls are out until you find some of
those so I felt like way away where
there's nobody just like and then it
would come out and generally I would
just like to roll a [ __ ] eye bra with
started smoking cigarettes I got it
rolled cigarettes and drying the Sun so
I went where there's nobody and I had
bad diarrhea so you are normally how you
know it wasn't like out of choice it was
out of necessity your eyes but also out
of love
like my pissing that Cup and in Hawaii
Gulf Cup so basically you left you left
in American market area by leaving the
[ __ ] and blood in the [ __ ] water so
yeah oh there was a lot of blood
I stopped wiping I just go straight to
shower now what if there are sharks
there and because your [ __ ] bleeding
you bet you bet it's giant small offer
so tested if sharks came I would not be
swim they didn't come this looks like
every like if match.com did a gay
section that's mismatched comm mi SS
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] stupid they're the [ __ ]
stupidest people I mean honestly you
guys could have them please if you want
you stupid [ __ ] morons my entire team
Bar None every single one of them
including the photographers take
pictures of me right now are [ __ ]
idiots oh I'm sorry and I apologize we
will do a crossover punch-drunk League
innocence episode in the next coming
weeks Oh that'd be awesome oh you'd love
that
I'd love that I love that but you guys
last week yeah we know him really well
Ari's higher than the right-half is at
[ __ ] jokes we did know Neil stepped
up when neither of you I was ready and
Sam [ __ ] [ __ ] tits brags about his
experience in my time it's just
disgusting never seen a
[ __ ] transparent climber dude who
brags about his hot girlfriend here's
what happen
nassim stroke just now you both think
and neither of you would step up and at
least Ryan [ __ ] on Neal okay but that
being said
long story short on that part long story
short that part you know you guys also
[ __ ] feel pretty goddamn stupid cuz
you talked a lot of [ __ ] and it wasn't
he just didn't do what you thought he
was gonna do yeah you won dude we gave
you props for how long are you gonna
months at a time how long you gonna mess
this are you wearing your belt right now
Jesus Christ
[Laughter]
lose how old are you how old are you
Luis Luis haldi I'm 36 you're 36
I'm 45 that's a huge [ __ ] it I'll
fight him and then maybe if I decide I
got a death wish I'll jump in with you
but I got fight Ari first that's the
original fight I'll fight no you are
ready
you [ __ ] Holocaust victim you weren't
[ __ ] ready hijinx both the last two
times I was ready say my to go to Reno
and son things never said about Reno in
the history of time he had a [ __ ] in a
hot tub [ __ ]
so I'm gonna fight already first I don't
know when the next opportunity will be
80 CFS I don't be at 80 CFS
I have an idea okay oh we do our own
fights
Ari Shaffir vs. Triple E as the [ __ ]
main event Ryan O'Neal will get him some
[ __ ] chick or whatever to fight
why don't you fight Oh jason Ellis haha
stumble all right then fight jason Ellis
you guys are the same size you guys are
the exact same size yeah so maybe you
should fight oh maybe you should fight a
lion
maybe you should fight a lion okay fine
bye Ari here's how it goes I fight Ari
all right Jason by any myth fight Smith
you fight Ellis okay that's a fight
that's a nice car yeah that SIBO can
fight that chicken fighter
yeah oh yeah then Timo can fight this
via the female fighter what a you
challenged other UFC learn oh yeah would
you like leg kicking treasons yeah yeah
yeah I just get on top of her and
grandma B and her P I don't want to see
you get kicked in half to your death
your body will see what do you think Ari
I like it
alright let's make it happen but but
Gomez has to fight jason Ellis I wanted
to hear Louis's weight and you cut him
off I want to hear that he's all the way
back to 230
he's probably do you gotta be better at
205 well he was at like 215 at the fight
you can gain 30 pounds in days Louis in
two weeks he could put on 15 pounds no
problem
now at the fight did you guys watch
Ellis versus Kyle Kings very yeah like
how big was that guy and he wasn't even
like a top 30 fighter yeah like that
dude was like so big and just shredded
maybe oh my god right I mean it's that
guy cuz he's crazy that's all he does is
he made so he did he did two and a half
hours of announcing and then thought
yeah and it was pretty packed man it's
pretty packed in there and it's the day
the weekend before Labor Day weekend so
that's a hard week in the film they do
the improvements three times the fights
the numbers yeah and Ryan didn't get a
dollar 75 seconds maybe no I know but
I'm just thinking Louis only got 500 so
it's like dollar
he should get a dollar loose yet more
than 500 just what you've earned Ryan a
dollar yeah Lycia free hotel see here's
the thing dude those guys prepared more
than anybody's ever prepared in history
of Alice mania right there everybody
shows up and throws yeah money they also
had more pressure on them than probably
anybody else a television gonna have to
suck big J's dick probably still doing
that right now
mm-hm I don't think that had anything to
do with a fight he just was looking for
an excuse to get that Wang in his mouth
the dudes 36 and 45 how am I supposed to
fight this guy why did he get up you're
not you and I Sam why did he get fun
easy fights yeah why did he get cuz I
saw on his Instagram Lewis's Instagram
he had a screenshot of said he got
kicked off a Twitter for like a day
because of you guys were John at each
other's oh he said called me a two-faced
[ __ ] Momo or something
I hit hahahahaha and then they kicked
him off so someone reported him he's
back so who even knows if he got kicked
off that could be him like look
I'm talking so much he deleted his
Twitter for a day dude remember the fat
chick the chick who made fun of fat
people and Shawn Halpin did a video back
yeah and she said Oh YouTube kicked me
off and then they did some invested all
these videos and acted like she got
kicked off I don't know did you really
yeah
yeah so everyone's like I'm such a
victim you're like you're not victim
dude Wow Lucas cries all right so he's
found love if a [ __ ] Jew can date a
Palestinian anyone can do it who's doing
that no she can't yeah let's doc I love
it boxing is a thing now oh yeah
everybody just showing like hey here's
her number and address that used to be
in the phonebook and for everybody yeah
like who gives a [ __ ] about a phone
number when you could just reach out to
somebody on Facebook or Twitter there's
no difference it's just different digits
into a thing so tell us tell us about
getting kicked off Twitter Louis tell us
about it I guess calling you a [ __ ]
which was I mean it's great with
different Twitter bands you for Sam even
though Twitter okay you know why you got
banned cuz Twitter knew you were full of
it and I'm not a [ __ ] and I'm a really
nice guy that helps people I feel like
Twitter watches us closely because of re
yeah our whole fiasco if they're gonna
ban me for just naming a simple fact
they should take down the entire uber
facts page that's what I say oh yeah
look at that I write back so we know she
would win that's how much I'll fight
I'll fight your son my son will [ __ ]
destroy your baby ma yeah she can't even
walk Oh
well yeah cuz all she can do is be on
the ground so your timer during murder
my baby maybe she has maybe she has good
ground Candice's baby obviously doesn't
want to take this keep this on her feet
because she's never stood before so
gomez do you have any felonies yes do
you have any white felonies felonies you
do have a felony face-i felony face it
might just be this close up angle hey
can we ask you about the fight night
loose Gomez who took a bigger beating
Rhino Neil or Kim Connors [ __ ] did you
did you wear the belt did you wear the
belt when you [ __ ] sorry I have stuff
to make up my legion really just gangs
compadres are upset that I'm doing
another show
Thank You the way we looked at Ari it's
like Ari's got a [ __ ] podcast so he's
scheduling another podcast right during
the same [ __ ] podcast people we're
not good people that's why you guys are
two mismatched calm that's how you guys
everybody wants to know when you were on
top of them and then they said go man
you gotta meet that shady [ __ ] that
promise if there's only one moment in
the fight I say is shady it's that
moment right there you earned everything
you battled through it that was a shady
moment I said it to Ryan I'll say to you
it was Shady
I'll give you that it wasn't the best
time for that year to come off for him
but I fought for that gear to be taking
off before and I wasn't kidding about it
I wasn't trying to be a tough guy
grappling with head gear [ __ ] sucks
dick and anybody who's done it before
will tell you did it makes it you guess
ten times quicker it's hotter and covers
your face so I didn't want to do it
because might get my goal was always to
you know
right with him but to get it down to the
ground eventually and try to you know
grapple with him or ground the pound
with him how'd that go for you I'm one
pretty damn good but I will say this and
he'll admit this too he did admit this
the headgear didn't mean [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude you take a little bit it's a little
bit more like it scratched his face and
stuff but the headgear is not actually
stopping like the thumping from those
punches and what it would have done was
it would have gassed him out quicker and
I probably would have went for the choke
instead because I if it would have
gotten my hands underneath the headgear
there's no getting it off dude you don't
need to need to have the choke in so it
was it actually helped him to take the
head girl but he also told me that he
didn't train in headgear there's no
[ __ ] way why did you do that because
there was part of the rules liability no
don't Sam oh it's up to you we could
talk about I don't care I want to wear a
suit of armor we use thicker gloves we
use nine ounce gloves that had the same
disbursement as 16 ounce sparring gloves
for boxing they were like the old
Ultimate Fighter gloves they had on the
first few seasons of The Ultimate
Fighter real thick ones they Hospital
yeah and they're open handed and I say
if you're trying to do [ __ ] head
kicks and [ __ ] I would have rather him
use shin guards and no headgear I just
show his headgear I said oh no [ __ ] was
a stupid move but at that point I was
like well [ __ ] dude it's gonna get
stood up once we were stood up again he
had every advantage in the world with no
head gear at that point like I kind of
go like you know we spent two more
rounds standing up and at that point you
know I mean yeah when I was on top of my
did a lot of ground-and-pound but I was
going for his chin I don't know how much
the headgear really made a difference in
it well I will tell you that I was very
impressed you kept pushing forward I was
kind of shocked that he he didn't throw
any punches and he said his arms were
just dead and he couldn't I mean like I
think he just thought he was gonna kick
your legs to death and it's like you you
haven't trained that long to be able to
do that I mean like who can kick the
legs of death Jose Aldo Anderson Silva
these guys have been taking around since
they were [ __ ] three-year-olds enough
[ __ ] hard thing to do and look for
like three days they were sore [ __ ] dude
yeah they were really I if you're a
black and blue I would have posted a
picture cuz I gotta give him props here
I feel like I listen to his podcast
yesterday and he was like I gotta [ __ ]
he gave me no props afterwards those be
shitty and I didn't look we all [ __ ]
around on these shows and my is my if
I'm not a humble dude you should have
[ __ ] fought me if he's looking for a
guy that's gonna come out and be like oh
but I gotta give him his props because
look he stepped up he was [ __ ] tough
did I wait like he'd punch me he hit me
in the jaw really [ __ ] hard a couple
knees in the third really hard leg kicks
really hard I just trained like a madman
I was obsessed and and people don't
understand the way that I get crazy
about [ __ ] and I found out after the
words he didn't train the same way that
I trained I was working with multiple
MMA coaches different gyms a lot of
jiu-jitsu a ton of sparring MMA sparring
two months out he started he did like a
week of MMA is boring so it was just a
different level of commitment so do you
go and listen to every podcast you think
that might mention your name that just
brings up your name whenever my name is
mentioned on a podcast it lets me know
[Laughter]
he did you start writing that down like
what's it called
so are we you know we I really mean it
Thank You Louis there's enough ethnic
time on this show we have to have it a
little diversity we had John put the Jew
back on real quick if we could I love
you guys thank you guys for supporting
you [ __ ] thank you for pointing your
fans in the wrong direction and having
them waste thousands of
maybe we'll be part of the next Al's
mania maybe we'll [ __ ] do our own
thing punch-drunk sports and leaving the
skanks presents [ __ ] comedian Fight
League who hold on with that I'm down
with for sure
Tony Tony Hitler said he would fight
O'Neill if O'Neill could make his way to
go well you'd have to cut him in half
with a buzzsaw to make your way an
Tony's group said he's the best fighter
at the Comedy Store
I swear to God that that's a direct
world who would you like to see fight
Tony within the reason of his weight I
mean who could it make his weight Yoanna
and a chick
what does he mean what is he mad if we
get cyborg to fight time I mean they are
the same way yes she would kill him
that's the point
kill you know how many people hate to
see that dude we would break the
Internet by the way listening to this
right now because he has that app Connor
Connor and Bing that the fight nannies
ever said I'm the history of her time on
pawn shop thank you I just saw I'm here
I'm here checking his taxes you guys are
you checking your texts on your [ __ ]
[ __ ] programs on your phone I don't
get I'm trying to get back to see you
guys where are you right now where is
this nice place with all this lush
greenery I'm in the backyard of the Luis
Gomez gasps digital fart analog studios
that's how successful he is at a studio
has a backyard
yeah New York City yeah that's
impressive put all the money into the
backyard and none of any of the
technical [ __ ] Ari do you own any piece
of gas digital no I started for analog
which is a competitor sorry - I must say
something to you that good run a podcast
I will refer
listen I don't like giving you
compliments but I'm going to I was very
impressed with how loved and worshipped
you are in New York City like I I I know
you've been out there for a while like
but every time you want on stage I was
really blown away by like how excited
everybody like you are in New York City
comic for sure and I so we always talk
about like comic trees right like who
like Rogen it's always the big
discussions Rogen's comic trees and now
they're either millionaires or people
who choose not to be millionaires but
they could be millionaires like re re
wanted to be a millionaire or he could
easily be a millionaire if he's not
already he just chooses the go I'm not
if you want if he wanted to follow the
rules so I believe that our he's got his
own tree now and his own tree is a New
York City tree and it's got in my
opinion odd legion skanks guys big J Joe
list ah that's it for right now but that
is his tree he has helped those yeah
those are people I try to help are
trying to send it over but I think Joe
list is part of like Bobby Kelley's true
okay so it's not your tree but I people
I've seen I do what Bobby Kelly could
not do which is like you don't hear that
get them stuff but you know this is a
[ __ ] up sex toy when none of the
directions are in English every language
but English as it is that still looks
like it would be I don't get who that's
helping I'm an I'm thinking I think it
keeps the blood and your dick so it
stays like like like really understand
hard what can i see you guys re what do
you do on israel's anniversary of 9/11
well
start off with and I can ice my most
breakfast then I go on to get a nice
like meal of tabbouleh just a
traditional 911 me off to boule you guys
there yeah we are here oh yeah my Jean
and then just blood of the infidel then
we count money for a while that's a
traditional Jewish thing
men on one side women on the other and
then we recreate the falling what we do
is we get up on like make a little human
not a pyramid but a human tower and then
somebody that runs through it's not just
in the back and then they kind of fall
over it'll kind of catch him oh I just
got a watch not gonna I just got a text
from our good friend Ryan Hill who
brought up a good point
hinge hinge cliff versus Biddle come oh
that's a great fight Brendan Brendan
it'll come we're putting together a
komedy Fight League Tony said he's the
best fighter at the store and it'll
fight anybody
I think UK dude he's a d1 baseball
player right guys shut up just go with
it nobody's gonna [ __ ] check that's
pretty good I was division six launched
arts high school oh maybe Bobby Lee
versus Bobby's too doughy seeing Bobby
fight would be so that would be we get
bigger now something crazy rich we
haven't seen him fight since re beat him
up three days in a row every time you
see me this is gonna happen you every
time you see me it's gonna be just like
this did he fight back at all Ari
like at all he used to call the store to
see if Ari was working I was and uh as
it was choking him he started like to
come at me like he wanted to resist that
choking and then and then I squeezed and
like it stopped and at what point did he
bend over and let you [ __ ] him in the
ass pretty pretty early in each fight
yeah take it about that that should be a
funny part of that Lou
to get to the two little munchkins
finally we got the silly spin down yeah
there it is
yes you Cocotte they're the winners blob
winner gets new coke out of the losers
but I load your [ __ ] phone we can see
you it's probably that awesome gas
digital [ __ ] Wi-Fi yeah there we go
okay uh-huh
what time is it guys awesome it's not
not late enough I'm sorry the guy Ryan
my friend Devon says he will fight Tony
Hinchcliffe if Tony wants to fight no
he's not funny some guys can't make it
Tony's wait Tony was 84 pounds Tony what
about Matt Edgar no Matt Edgar Matt
Edgar would be a good funny I'm saying
Bobby Lee hasn't fought since he was in
high school 35 years ago antonius look
says do the best one so Bobby weighs way
more than amazing the opportunity see
Tony get punched in the face I'm the
Bobby Lee who could easily like try to
do I really probably would dress funny
like the whole thing would be barred
make it hilarious but I don't think
there'd be much fighting if red BAM was
completely out of shape breadbin twisted
his knee just like walking in a concert
a concert Reggie Torres blew his ACL and
MCL Smith from the Legion of skanks he's
kind of thin baby yeah hey his
girlfriend's having a baby our babies
could fight that's more fair I would
love a baby I would love the groom they
have that like Chechnya or whatever did
you watch that [ __ ] real sports
yeah no I'm talking about like babies
babies babies the playground abandoned
that kind of [ __ ] like just like ten
babies in the [ __ ] thing everyone's
crying and only one baby gets out alive
guys we're gonna put together this
komedy Fight League and it will be
brought to you by bat DSi bet DSi for
all your bet needs that's right go to
Betty si.com use the promo code punch 25
get $25 betting cash and then whatever
you put in your
thing whatever you put in your account
boom you get doubled that's right yeah I
just like to say Betty si he's been our
sponsor for a long time and one thing we
like about them is let us say whatever
the [ __ ] we want
you're a promo reads yep they know who
we are and they're [ __ ] good spawns
and they know who you are today whatever
the [ __ ] you want just give the promo
code and just [ __ ] send people our
way they're wonderful what a great
sponsor to work I love them very much
and you know what let's do this let's
look at the NFL schedule for week one
and let's try to put together like a
parlay so you guys could this will be
your punch-drunk parlay of the week
there's a couple easy ones too
hey what do you guys think about
Kaepernick getting made uh Nike I think
it's you know it is what it is I like it
wasn't from this team yeah it's like
kind of a long story but yeah I know why
he's not sign with the team why that
hair the whole kneeling thing this is
gonna rock the sports world a little bit
okay the whole kneeling thing was not
because of protests to the police it
just what he said here's week me as you
guys he did a robbery wanted to say it
for him but he's done he's athletic Lee
he's finished can you look up Colin
Kaepernick's last season playing police
he statistics I'd like to know his
statistics
Jason was he okay okay was he a good
quarterback he he absolutely should be
in the NFL he's better than almost every
backup yeah and he probably could start
four or five three stringers oh he's
better than every third stringer in the
NFL lets his quarterback rating in his
last season in San Francisco 90.7 solid
he had twenty two hundred yards 16
touchdowns four interceptions Wow how
many how many games though that was
seven gay 12 games 11 game started wow
that's good pretty good is pretty good
by the way you I guarantee you if there
wasn't collusion one of the GM's one of
them would have said I'll pay you the
league minimum come here start
straighter and
what happens I'll play the league
minimum he got offered a gig from Denver
they wanted to trade for him he turned
it down
no that's before all this yeah but and
then that's fine people do that all the
time in the NFL he restructured his deal
but you still find it yeah all of those
things that he did all of those things
he did weren't and he probably would
have done those things if he anticipated
he was gonna get blacklisted which is
clearly is yeah exactly
John Elway said nobody just offer him a
league made him contract said it John
Elway said 26 to do seven million
dollars a season over two seasons in
2016 mmm-hmm that's what 14 million I
didn't want it I mean why not why not go
to like I don't know Jacksonville go
like yep be our third stringer guitar
now yeah he could start in Jacksonville
sure he could be bortles no problem he
doesn't want to get hit anymore and he's
slowly but surely becoming this civil
rights leader and he's making more than
that how is he okay Brady get a mr.
stranger there's no [ __ ] controversy
we needed somebody to be the third
stringer so we gotta get somebody the
league minimum so give it to this guy in
case the worst happens so it's the best
third stringer bargaining in history he
for sure be a backup he would be like
the second quarter yeah there be no
controversy I was starting it needs to
go to an offense that fits his skill set
great example the panthan you would be a
good backup for Carolina you know I
totally agree I think what I think if
cam knew never got hurt we might
actually give him a look because our
cerebral Sam yes I will be in studio the
week okay when is that he says that like
everyone knows that date 2020 October
1st 2020 cents over twentieth this is
his wedding so that means it'll be the
22nd all right that's all ATC fest all
right and by the way Tuesday 911 Suzy
before it's yeah our 300th episode
Tuesday 911 September 11th
I love that as counting it now 300 is
gonna be so big because 299 was a
[ __ ] episode we've we've turned it
around oh yeah I mean there's gonna be a
lot at it and just think of their show
as just as bad as ours no they didn't
start their show they did because he was
pissed
watching us they came down yelling cuz
Luis left their pot yeah we [ __ ]
tobogganing that they're both out there
Ari [ __ ] two podcasts up by being ran
yeah you're gonna have a hot dog in your
I know go with that and I'm not against
it
but where are the other [ __ ] pays off
guys we are like this just being a
[ __ ] already so we can get this dance
please trans yeah I am now I am now back
from Scotland and Croatia
I'll get the begging done I'm gonna
start on the begging I don't think today
I don't get he's not gonna over one day
do it over many days there's no way I'm
gonna I'm not we'll see maybe maybe I'll
get like a 20 no way I'm getting a 20 no
you're re they're gonna give you money
and you'll be done and no I can't do
that right I'm all to say like hey give
me money for this thing
no you got a dress up you gotta look
like a hobo I mean you got smear [ __ ] on
your face I mean that's not hard
friended yeah why can't you why do you
keep stomping this thing down all you
have to do is sit and run a bit yeah you
literally just have to sit upright I
know I need to lay on the ground when I
do a podcast I'll come in with a hot dog
in my ass I got talking about oh he
doesn't care he'll put a hot dog in that
[ __ ] oh that thing yeah that's like
so thin a hot dog could fit not know
about it no one can get their dick in it
that's Bobby when I did a bunch of coke
I could have tried having my
I came out of the packet now saying oh
yeah I'm gonna go over this week one I
don't know I got a look at who's playing
who
I know Falcons okay we have Cowboys and
Panthers [ __ ] the Cowboys we're gonna
lose gotta make a statement right away
we're gonna get in that ass
oh not touch it I wouldn't want to touch
that game oh dude the Panthers are
probably going off a big favorite on
that one you think the Panthers gonna
win I guarantee you they're favored in
that game Oh New York traffic you're
very like no [ __ ] well do a podcast
of a thousand noises I got the text from
Ryan saying he'll fight Tony - I love
that everyone's listening texting
everybody I'll fight I'll fight Ryan
I'll fight Tony I got the text as well
Ryan
another thing everybody you're creeping
everybody out a mustard sandwich even
got the text oh hi Bobby
Panthers are two and a half point
favorites against the Cowboys I'm gonna
go with Cowboys that is ridiculous
Panthers are a two point favorite two
and a half points to my favorite listen
two and a half gobblers gotta make a
statement they got went to their first
array for sure I have to pick somebody
I'll say Carolina but I wouldn't put
money on that game I could easily see
the Cowboys don't you know that DSi
groaning pounding yeah do not know you
don't know what I'm saying that's the
week
- not that money on that game yeah yeah
that's basically I wouldn't touch that
what else we got Falcons and eagles
eagles favored by two and a half I take
the Falcons Annette adem has an underdog
DeMars an underdog they got a backup
quarterback starting and we're the
underdog I'll take that Super Bowl poses
look like [ __ ] in the preseason he's
looked absolutely terrible the guy who
won the Super Bowl
he's the best guy then he should start
all season he is
starting I'll see you guys not healthy
the other guy well okay
buffalo buffalo the best quarterback
there though Buffalo at Baltimore Ravens
are favored by seven I would take the
Ravens of sevens in a lot of points are
you guys picking against the spread or
just money yeah you're gonna have to bet
on the spread so let's go with this
friend of mine to you who's out Ravens
are at home there oh yeah yeah I mean
and the points yeah I picked the Ravens
Bengals at Colts Colts are favored by
3-3 I'm gonna go Andrew Luck shows up
and shocks the world I like that - I
like the Colton at threes not alive it's
so [ __ ] loud here
I love Liddy's walking the streets
shirtless on skype yeah it's September
we get your New Yorker we get it are
your New Yorker Texans at Patriots
Texans a Patriots Patriots are favored
by six and a half
oh that's actually a patriot yeah I like
the Texans in that I do too I like the
Texas that Watson could stay healthy
he's I think he will he's good I think
he will four blocks I'm home I have a
question and a possible vet jag Jags a
giant's Jaguars going on what re no
first four games I'm thinking of a
double or nothing bet before October
23rd starts okay okay hold on on best
record October 20th I wanted to see the
[ __ ] talkin schedule oh just a second
Falcons cowboys and and Raiders you mean
do the Raiders aren't gonna be that
great I'm not in ok ok no Sam's out but
Jason me and you maybe go double or
nothing I gotta look at this schedule
would you be willing to do that ok
you're ready for it can you hear can you
hear re ok Falcons at eagles falcons at
home versus the Panthers Falcons at home
versus the Saints
Falcons at home versus the Bengals we
win three out of four of those probably
yeah and then what what date is that
that takes to October 20th that takes
you to 30th 30th of September that gets
you to the end of September re no all
the way till October 20th 21st I mean
okay then they're at the Steelers
Falcons at the Steelers stuff Falcons at
home versus the Buccaneers and then all
the way to this can you go to the 22nd
or you want to stop at the 20th stop at
the 22nd okay Giants at home versus the
Giants in Eagles Eagles Panthers Saints
Bengals Steelers bucks Giants and that's
how many game about the Cowboys that's
seven games
okay Cowboys at the Panthers I could
easily be four and three though home
versus the Giants home versus the Giants
at Seattle home versus the home versus
the Lions Oh at-at the Texans home
versus the Jaguars
and then at Washington that's a lot
easier than mousketool it is they're on
the road even though we're a better team
you guys are at home a lot more they're
on the road a lot more so you're nothing
but I think you are two hot dogs in your
ass if you lose or double or one bit or
what or or or winner just has to absorb
one of the losers bet do you want though
that means okay so one means I stays at
one but you also get one if I win Sam
wants the Raiders schedule here we go
Rams that's that's my lock of the week
Rams at Broncos at Dolphins Browns at
sea at UH the Chargers and then home
versus the Seahawks home versus the
Colts that's pretty easy right there
what's your first time that's an easy
schedule home Rams bat that's a bat
Broncos at Dolphins home Browns and at
chargers home versus the Seahawks homers
and the Colts aridity Raiders could be
five and two dolphins the Seahawks
aren't gonna be good Seahawks does it
for probably three of the worst teams in
the NFL
coming up what's the spread of that Rams
game though because that could be 25 and
up might still take the ramps if that
things under to anything under 10 that's
my lock of the week that's mine it's -5
the spread in that one so ramp Rams
favored by Raiders at Los Angeles rice
Angeles at Oakland oh la at Oakland
Monday night Monday Night Football
so that's gonna be a juice this is gonna
be pretty juiced up there in Oakland
from Monday night game man I I just like
the way McVeigh prepares these guys III
would take that as my bet DSi lock of
the week Rams over Raiders room five
point spread rude I'll run through the
other lines real quick Jets at Detroit
Lions are favored by six and a half if
you have any strong feeling styling Jet
Set Detroit there we go
bears at Packers Oakland so will be a
home go scans at Cardinals that's a
pick'em skins at Cardinals
I like Wow [ __ ] that's tough that's a
picking right I mean I'd go with
Washington in that game I think Seahawks
at Broncos Broncos and favorite by three
it's so hard to bet week one cuz you
haven't seen [ __ ] what I'd also take a
lot of overs take a lot of overs week
one
Casey yet the Chargers Chargers are
favored by three I take I think the
Chargers are gonna be really good this
year I think this is a year they put I
think it'll be good here's the thing
about overs in week one here's why you
guys one about overs in week one
nobody has any film to watch of any
place yet from your opponent what is
going on
are you flushing your toilet what are
you doing I'm back home oh my god Titans
at Dolphins Titans are favored by one
you live that close to that place what I
was like a five-minute walk
I got that yeah the studio Buccaneers
that Saints inks are favored by nine and
a half and that one he also just bailed
on a podcast right that's a lot yeah
that's a lot I mean they're gonna win
that game but that's a lot of [ __ ]
employment I would take that I would
take the points in Tampa yeah 49ers at
Minnesota Vikings are favored by six in
that one what's interesting
hmm yeah I would also take a lot of
overs if you think any gave me one a bet
on just take the overall Miller's that
brown Steelers are favored by five and a
half points no love for the Hard Knocks
that's it just so weird this Le'Veon
Bell thing like is he ever gonna show up
is he just gonna pull up to the field a
game day and be like alright I'm back do
you want to risk hurting in there I mean
like why why even why I wouldn't play if
I was him like he's mean but he's proven
that he can just show up and play in the
past so let him just but he hasn't he
wants to hold out let him ran any plays
any seven on seven s he hasn't done one
single thing with this team and he did
but football starts in five days he
hasn't practiced once he hasn't even
spin around his teammates he's been in
Florida the entire time it's like hey me
his linemen need to feel that that
[ __ ] tempo because he stops in the
backfield [ __ ] waits for his a baby
you know like he generally stops his
[ __ ] so it's like they're not gonna be
up to like the teammate situation I mean
any new plays that have been implemented
into the playbook you wouldn't even know
what that is like yeah kind of thing
they got him to PlayBook at least right
don't you think man like when I would
imagine but I mean that does not say
he's reading it or getting accustomed to
this this is where their general manager
yesterday he said we were disappointed
that he has not signed his franchise
tender and rejoined his teammates we're
gonna continue to focus on preparing the
players so they're gonna play without
them yeah yeah so I don't know I wonder
what that does to that spread to who's
their backup do you know John Connor I
know I know they got John Connor the
Terminator but I think he's our full
belt that's pretty good there
yeah he's like a cyborg and [ __ ] it is
James Conner is it James yeah y'all from
Pittsburgh right now remember that guy
he was good in college yeah he's real
good in college I like how Steven Ridley
so shitty that they skipped third string
on the depth chart and just put him
fourth string they don't have anybody
thirsty yeah that's a real bad sign
right there
ari are you gonna go to new Yankee games
or anything while you're out there dude
so they're on there they were at home
before they're on the road until I'm in
Austin so I can't see another game until
and I will see this one the play in game
it'll be about October 2nd or 3rd and
I'll be home for it and I'll go to that
I went last year too we came back three
noting down the first inning
how great was that atmosphere dude it
had to be crazy right it was crazy but
the craziest I've ever been to and with
Yanis was when they came back in game 4
would have been down 3-1 they were down
by three runs in the seventh with this
so they mounted a comeback and the plate
it was so loud and so crazy for so
consistently cuz hit after hit after hit
and then they didn't just tie it up they
extended it
people were hugging babies were getting
born it was amazing people get knocked
up yeah Ari I want to send you this
[ __ ] sex toy that we got where did
you get this Johnny it was just oh
really yeah I thought like I got it
somehow I didn't even know yeah I'm Way
in the concrete has a 6:00 p.m. football
draft so we used to go get one 1:30
by the way Jason's going to the same
draft and you gotta get your [ __ ] I'll
see you in an hour is an hour doubly
nothin or double or one better all right
I explained it to me though I don't I
don't I don't understand what the
ramifications are of it if he you
explain if I win or whoever wins yeah
yeah the options are either if we lose
I'm sorry if we lose that means we take
two hotdogs to the bus
and if we win the options are either we
take zero hotdogs to the but yeah but I
didn't lose the hotdogs but yeah he
didn't lose a hotdog bed that doesn't
make sense for him so I would have to
take one or you would have to take two
it's either the options are either if I
lose I take two but if I win the options
are either I take zero or you take one
hmm
so I really can't lose no you tell us
ahead of time which one do you want you
want to take zero as your bet or me for
zero or you for one if you lose can I
take two is there a way I got two well
Ari will you take some of his
outstanding bets is that something that
could happen oh [ __ ] what do you have
here's what I was saying will we make
this bet winner loser has to take one of
the winners outstanding BET's off I have
shock collar afterwards shot caller for
a whole episode or or triangle and I
have to walk I have to dress like a
[ __ ] and walk around in like [ __ ]
town and you got it the USA chant one's
easy bro I can't believe I've knocked
that one out both the minor Lambrettas
[ __ ] are you I thought it was only
twenties at 40 40 bucks if we do any
more no but he's never no you're right
half of his other bets he didn't pay off
he says he did he like half-hearted yeah
the hot dog which I know I don't touch
his [ __ ] like barely and he'd be like
done we did it
is that the other one he has that
gentleman he's right Sam yeah and he's
been wearing a luchador mask on his ass
oh yeah hmm by the way pretty sure he
didn't inhale on the fart funnel yeah I
have a reason to believe
of course not now you remember the Pugh
beard he was Curt like screaming that it
was on fire that one he did that was a
good no breeze like it's a fire I got to
get it off and we're like it's like nah
I was like nothing by the way hey Ari we
found out Tebow has been blocked on
Twitter by Sam for the past like two
months basically oh no he did it cuz he
was pissed he did it because they had a
little argument or something and then he
blocked his ass I'll show him he said he
said he blocked me because of the use of
thing yeah cuz he said I set him up and
now is my plan the whole time okay yeah
dude that's how I was gonna scheme
against you I go what could I do to
really [ __ ] him over I'm gonna get Yusef
as a guest and they can talk about
Instagram comments what a diabolical
plan that was of mine and the funny
thing is I didn't even know we were
tight on the patreon he goes oh yeah I
just unblocked you like he was doing you
a big favor
I'm a near a Jew lations he goes yeah
man I had you block for like the last
two months or something I didn't even
know it's blocked that's how much I look
at all that I don't look at that [ __ ] I
don't look at any I don't look at any of
that
I don't either I just look at my replies
now yeah that's all I really will look
at see if anybody says Annie if I need
to reply to something yeah I'll look at
what people are hitting me up about Sam
but I don't like go through Twitter and
think about you all the time Instagram I
kind of go through a lot I like
Instagram that's my favorite Instagram I
only really follow friends yeah like I
have a lot of followers no a lot I'm not
like alright but you know a couple
thousands or whatever but I only follow
like a hundred and ten people so I like
personally know everybody that I follow
yeah cuz then I could just scroll
through Instagram and kind of see what
everybody is up to you know like I ran
into Marilyn Rice cop the other day and
I was like hey how was Hawaii how was
that
you know I'm shoot you did her and you
know that this looks fun and that looked
cool and she's like wow you I don't even
really need to talk to you you know
everything that's going on yeah that's a
problem
you don't [ __ ] you've seen everything
yeah you feel like you're still friends
with everyone and no one's really in
touch with each other
I've watched children grow up from
people that I haven't talked to in seven
years I haven't seen them in like six
seven years like friends back home and
[ __ ]
had a baby now the kids walk and I see
the kid right know what's crazy all the
milestones like four especially you and
I re because we're so old I probably
have like I don't know maybe like a
hundred ish photos of me as a child no
videos there's no audio I don't know
what my voice sounded like as a three
year old right now everything is
documented for every child alive the nhd
like yeah yeah in HD all do these
children's your daughter is going to be
able to look at her entire life yeah I
have like black-and-white photos that
are blurry and that's an interesting
thing because you can look at the video
now even old video you could tell it's
old but now think like 20 years from now
they're gonna be looking at [ __ ] 4k
video it's gonna look just like it was
taken last week you know I'm saying I
don't there's a video of my firt me
walking for the first time there's no
funny videos that you could [ __ ] you
know I don't know my voice sounded like
by the way my dad has one video of me
and he's like I wish I had more videos
of yeah yeah yeah and now everybody does
oh it's Tebow someone has offered to let
you use their Costco membership on one
shopping spree to again the fantasy
football leagues oh I thought we were
missing one person if anybody having
throw their credit card in there too and
they then they're good I think that's
what well and you can use their laundry
room twice bus fare included where is
this no I don't know in Iowa yeah take a
bus to Iowa to do laundry I'm good I
think we're set for the well we have a
let we have 11 if the guy with the pube
beard comes through more weight or the
pubes sandwich or whatever the [ __ ] the
cottage the video of the of the oru you
missed it yeah you probably can't see it
what but we played the video of the guy
telling his seven-year-old Santa Claus
doesn't exist for the first time
that's just something he's submitted to
get into the fantasy league Oh yep you
do that you are in and he sent it to us
we played it earlier while you guys were
trying to land airplanes over at [ __ ]
gas digital [ __ ] news he had like a
panic attack yeah he's like kind of like
slap himself he's like I don't know I
don't know what to do he was like kind
of almost like seemed embarrassed or
like his head exploded hey so real quick
we got a 17 year old kid who has offered
to eat a Carolina Reaper but he can't do
that before the draft so instead he'll
do that later next week and in the
meantime he's offered to eat a load of
Schiller dog treats do we let do we let
this gentleman in 17 years old young
wait he wants to do both things well I
think yeah you'll still do their who
just wants to eat dog treats put a [ __ ]
of it and then he's gonna wash it down
with a reaper
well we what the idea is we probably get
something in before the draft you know
dog [ __ ] but if you think dog treats is
just cool to get him in then we can do
that right now he's just in a photo he's
like can I eat these and a lot of them
no yeah okay like what too big I can
tell he pukes he said he's got to sign a
waiver to eat the pepper by the way his
uncle it grows him or something he's
like like if I die you know like my
uncle can't go to jail okay I wonder
somebody would commit murder to be in
early no he's too big but a big handful
of sure why not okay if we got one spot
left and he's gonna [ __ ] Reaper it up
later but just tide us over with that
pan full of dog biscuits what if they're
delicious what if he just turns out that
he loves them oh ah that's too mean I'll
just say what about a bunch of dog
biscuits in a bowl and then put milk
over and eat it like it's cereal I don't
think that's mean I really think you
should do it till he pukes I feel like
I've been the mean when I'm like
scalding hot yogurt oh wait that's a
good idea actually there's a milk okay
sure do it like cereal okay yeah yeah my
to make it taste better to be honest
it's like cookies and milk dog cookie
yeah they taste like beef or something
yeah I might be like beefy milk have you
seen those cookie dog treats those are
actually sweet I've been told by you
they're like they look they're pink and
stuff like when you go to pet smart
little kids I need for sneak them and I
think little Esther eats those for fun
I think she's talked about that on
podcast she looks so skinny yeah she
does
I think that's being on TV you get it
like in your head there yeah when a girl
nobody says wow you look great
yeah Louisville looks kind of weird thin
like his face looks like drama yeah well
you know it looks great is a joke
bartnik rain a lot of ways yeah he looks
some people don't like when they lose a
lot of weight they still have a big
[ __ ] head you don't think our neck
has a big head yeah and you can tell
they're meant to be kind of fat I don't
like women especially that lose they're
really big and lose low with their head
it's still [ __ ] huge
what are you of course
how is the candy over there like lion
bars and it's got a lot of different
stuff it's pretty good and I didn't have
much of it in Croatia but in Scotland
for sure all the UK [ __ ] did you get
laid at all he has a girlfriend yeah in
Scotland but not in Croatia she doesn't
care I get scared like she's gonna
listen
it's probably an open relationship your
girlfriend oh yeah she's so genuine no
she doesn't like it
did she just rate up ask you and you
just tell her the truth yeah wasn't that
a rule though you told this a long time
ago like on the road you're allowed to
do whatever is what you is what you told
her sweet person I'm free American oh
this is true anyone can sleep with
anyone whatever they
I'm not arguing well that's not exactly
true it technically is can she sleep
with other people
Oh God da she she better not I get what
you're saying but I feel like guys like
that are pissed when girls do it I'm
gonna try to find out
look at him rolling his eyes he's like
there's one way for me to find out all
right what did you find out Sam and I
both gave her a nice hammer in the look
of terror in his face when he just
remotely entertained that idea to be
true the brief moment that he was like
oh gosh that would really get her a
[ __ ] just like it I guess I'll get
her a mustard sandwich to the eye God
that would be horrible you ever like
hook up with somebody than you find out
are you like you date him and you
actually like them and then you find out
somebody you just despised gave her a
nice spray down I feel like it's always
Tony hunch or somebody you know video of
him really dirty you know I'm saying
yeah somebody that you never would want
to [ __ ] after they did but you unlike
want to go in the bathroom at but you're
like okay I mean do you guys just [ __ ]
once or you were drunk or something oh
no I was we dated for a long time I
really liked him and you hate the guy
tail yeah yeah yeah
not only do can you not get it out of
your head Carola say this in the
beginning it would be like haha [ __ ]
this guy's girlfriend and then after
like two months you like yeah yeah it's
like that yeah you know most likely in
the comedy scene of all your friends
yeah - [ __ ] ex-girlfriend so far and
just like not tell you not be like hey
would you mind just too far Jeff dannis
he got my ex-girlfriend pregnant who do
i okay I should be saying and just to be
like but be shady about it like there
was not through it and just Sam Tripoli
I mean that happened with you I mean
with you that happen
Duncan did that with you know we talked
about beforehand oh you did okay cuz he
kept that quiet for a long time like no
one he just kept saying he had a girl's
way so how did that go or he like asked
permission
Zoe using yeah I think so like that
you did that to me once what hit me up
like many months after I was not seeing
somebody and you're like hey hey what's
uh what's going on with you too because
I saw her the other day and I kind of
wanted to [ __ ] her and I'll say simbari
and I was like go for it I mean we're
friends but there's nothing between us
like a fat banker would is this gonna be
a bad thing or well and the other thing
is as all of us know here it's such an
incestuous group yeah you know and
everybody's been different there's
people that I hang out with at the store
and and improv and all the yeah I forget
that we had sex before it's hard to look
like our only social circle I mean it's
we're all around each other and it's a
big enough pool of us yeah that you
can't and we're all [ __ ] and we're all
always stoned and drunk and late-night
hanging out and sometimes you're like
hailey good yeah yeah yeah you know what
I never thought about this but we should
[ __ ] totally smash this up who do you
think it would be the the the weird time
of guys and not girls that would just I
don't know him he's married no no back
in the day Oh Josh Adam Meyers I feel
like he would Josh Martin would try and
fail God and so it just Meyerowitz
yeah my roots really does like hit on
anything the walk singles am I out of
line yeah
anything that walks I yes yes oh yeah I
wouldn't turn my back to trip leave out
of fear of him loading it up with dick
you should not send your back yeah
yeah bro that's what I do
here's another suggestion this guy will
eat a hot dog after letting it roll
across the wall more bathroom floor I
would know I wouldn't want that on
somebody yeah that's too much a person
is not right in the house like I go into
me I don't know what do you think Ari
that'd get you in the league yeah yeah I
make video of it I would love that I
would love that
okay me too I would love that I don't
condone that okay right watch it be
gross yeah well I mean wall to wall Oh
1999 Bryan Callen I don't know I mean
Dave [ __ ] it all
Mike young way back in the day - does
Mike young what you mean oh you same why
you're currently dating oh oh yeah yeah
yeah that's what I thought you meant
that's how I taught you man what about
girls at all that's Jill Allen that's it
oh yeah mm-hmm
I never see her you know I wonder who I
don't know there's somebody those all
those young kids I don't really know
know like a lot of those new ones that
you just see hanging out all the time I
was thinking the other day like you know
we're too old like nobody really offers
us drugs and nobody invites us to
parties anymore were you invited to
anywhere yesterday any barbecues I
didn't even remember it was holiday
until no we were 30 me and Jeff we're on
a walk with like the baby and then we
were walking past all these barbecues
and I was like I wasn't invited anywhere
today were you and he doesn't like we're
not cool anymore yeah that's I think
that just happens and then I didn't know
I forgot it was a holiday and I was I
was watching oh that's when I was
blowing through [ __ ]
those are Ozarks I watched like six
episodes of that which is like you know
five it's it's really good yeah okay so
I got like almost finished it on Monday
and I was gonna go to friends and family
I knew his you know I could get a spot
in and and then I'd [ __ ] first time I
looked at Instagram it was just like
parties parties parties barbecue
everybody's in a pool
everyone there's a couple parties right
like I know every single person in this
pool right now cuz usually it's like
David Taylor ran as easy and I don't
think they did anything right yeah no no
no so that's what Dave Taylor doesn't
anymore yeah but I used to be the big
ones right but like those ones it was
like everybody at the store would be at
yeah like Fantana pool
Jeff Ross had one I don't think he likes
me too much yeah that's not like my crew
but everybody there I knew yeah but yeah
I didn't I did I didn't get invited
anything no I'm glad we're all on the
same boat yeah old hole didn't nobody
loves us anymore
what a great boat to be in Candace why I
had a baby I'm not as old as you guys is
to be fair I just don't know anybody
annoying that's a good argument Mari and
I we're [ __ ]
baby good argument are you never go
anywhere what you have a Labor Day party
yesterday
what there was no Labor Day parties in
New York or barbecues re still cool just
re so coolly tells bedtime stories to
his girlfriend about all the girls he
had sex with on the road right oh she
was so hot we took matching shits in the
[ __ ] Rhine River ari took a [ __ ] like
in Runyon Canyon remember with Ryan
O'Neal and didn't wipe and capital try
to throw it at a mountain re [ __ ]
everywhere patreon.com slash punch-drunk
sports if you want to listen to the [ __ ]
story oh that was on there yeah
Judah's nice little [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
weird bodies of water but why do you
think you don't need to wipe that one
makes sense you're in water but why do
you think on a hike you don't have to
wipe and you can just put your hands in
the dirt cuz Ryan makes you feel you
can't hold it though man like you don't
have that kind of tight and he's eating
a huge bag of gummy bears right now so
it's like his diets do you have a lot of
diarrhea yeah if I go home and [ __ ] or
I'm not gonna make it - oh you're all
sweaty and your butt's all crusty you go
home and [ __ ] I mean that's the move
totally for somebody so successful
you're such a [ __ ] caveman - like you
can afford to take a [ __ ] nice [ __ ]
are you still smoking cigarettes but now
that you're back home alright yeah
welcome back welcome back ah
[Music]
AJ ass it was great already what I just
said oh let me do this it's all gone
then I'm done what got you smoking
cigarettes because your splits they
don't smoke joints so if you want to get
high you [ __ ] smoke a joint with
[ __ ] tobacco in it and after a while
it's got that contain in there so you be
so through smoking so many spliffs you
start your body started to crave
nicotine well I'm a smoker and I don't
like splits at all I just like weed and
then I like cigarettes I don't like weed
and cigarettes together oh really
I don't like spliffs well because I'm
already I already already smoked tobacco
like straight tobacco you didn't mean so
when I smoke pot I'm gonna smoke pot I
don't want to smoke half-half cigarette
right do you get a lot of free drugs in
Scotland ari
it was great so I have a bucket after my
shows yeah go outside say hey if you
like that sub many of you didn't pay
anything so now comes a time where you
give me what you think it's worth
and you got to go outside and wait with
the bug it's like a normal done thing
there and I mean you get money but you
don't forget like I got weed MDMA
mushrooms acid cocaine
what else did I get coin this from all
over the world that was cool
you trust it or you give it away even
the MDMA I mean those pressed pills
those are kind of scary well the MDMA
even you trusted even that this press
pills are kind they always kind of make
me nervous I can't imagine
whoa what was the DMT trip like did you
do it in Scala knob I mean how is the
latest trip did you oh made of [ __ ] his
pants and I mean was it anything
profound disappointing I thought we're
gonna get a whole party together like 10
people DMT 24 night okay the next time
you're out is for the wedding and then
you're going to be here and then you
were gonna go to Phoenix together right
yeah by the way this guy is on his way
to Walmart now alright
what's he like driving and was like hey
I have an idea open a package I had to
be well look honey I'm gone I'm going to
Walmart you need anything
[Laughter]
yeah like I'll roll it like a bowling
ball roll like a bowling ball
yeah but no skidding no skidding over
like have it roll and then swirl it
around the toilet seat and under the
toilet do that see if you can don't make
it mandatory but try to get rid do it
I'm sending him that now he oh god I
hope he doesn't do that so he doesn't
get sick alright guys let's wrap it up I
gotta head to the comedy store because
our lives
NFL fantasy football draft is in 40
minutes and punch notes
draft is tonight so if you're in the
league and you listen to this live I
will see you online at 6 o'clock 9
o'clock Eastern as always thanks for a
good friends with pet DSi don't forget
about subscribing to our patreon page we
just put up another good episode the
other day and no but enough bets were
made between our us and them that the
line had changed several times yeah the
line changed several times so you knew
there was action going down on it wow
that's so cool but and I will tell you
this it was fun as [ __ ] watching a live
stream of it from Edinboro I [ __ ] it for
4 a.m. I did a fight companion at the
Comedy Store a [ __ ] basement really
yeah and everybody was down there to
like so like no one could get drinks at
the counter cuz all the bartenders and
waiters were and waitresses were down so
I was watching that fight rogue it was
like any did I'm like they're about to
go in that's really cool at Rogan watch
well I just want to say this real quick
Ryan has a has really bad eyesight
alright do you have do you know what
prescriptions he's -6 his eyesight and
he didn't have any corrective lenses in
so yeah I mean I did we just found that
out yeah isn't that crazy though like
that's my prescription and dude I hear
there's no way I can punch coming like
yeah like if you could really we're just
totally [ __ ] Ryan's crazy that makes
it even crazier know what that means
about
well let him get full guard full [ __ ]
mouth on you there's nothing to do with
that [ __ ] alright taking you down
get a [ __ ] half guard don't your side
alright well welcome back buddy I'm glad
you're back I'm glad your trip went good
I'm glad you [ __ ] in a [ __ ] river you
dumb [ __ ] not a river to see well not
anymore all right so you guys suck it
suck it suck it Aaron thanks bye dude
deal with them